question for you so you know the the we
had oliver stone on uh last week and uh
uh so i went on a binge watching of all
these jfk assassination documentaries
i've already interviewed way too many
people on that topic but just something
i'm curious about how jfk wanted to get
rid of the cia i'm sure you've read the
story somewhere which one of these
organizations can america do without so
i'll give you the list and you tell me
so and i hope you're not going to be
politically correct just to give a safe
answer you got cia you got fbi you got
pd you got dea you got the irs you got
all which one of these guys can we go
without and it would probably make
america a better place can we put
congress on the list yeah wait i was
gonna say could we put uh yeah could we
play you didn't pull rick perry and
forget the names that you were gonna ask
oops
we gotta get rid of these three agencies
i can only name two though i apologize
you know the cia the the bureau um dea
um
you know
i would i would argue you can't get rid
of any of those right there so there's a
real reason why those exist now you know
at times the bureaucracies get too big
you know
yeah fine but um you know it's like when
people say we gotta get rid of you know
customs and you know border patrol uh or
ice get rid of these
it's a simplistic way of you know
looking at it and when it comes from a
politician it's they're just blowing
smoke up people's ass to you know score
a point you know right because it's
popular to say it so
um irs
yeah you know do we need it to to
enhance the size of the irs i don't
think so are taxes a good thing in if
they're used properly sure yeah so
you know i'm probably not the best
person to talk about this but definitely
don't get rid of the cia right it is it
is a [ __ ] up world out there and you
need
uh i'll say a political you need an
apolitical intelligence service right is
the cia a political these days yeah i
mean i would again it's it's
you know it it
it gets uh it it's had a it had a
beating uh about the same time that the
bureau was taking a beating you know and
um
but
my experience that's all i can talk to
i was in the operations side of things
and um you know i'd spent my whole time
overseas so
i never saw it as a political
organization right we i never had
political conversations with any of the
guys that i was working with right we'd
sit in a safe house for three weeks
waiting for something to pop we didn't
sit there talking politics it just
wasn't it wasn't something you did and
when i'd come back and walk the
corridors in in the main building
yeah there were political discussions so
you never had that feeling that that
that's how that build and you don't want
that i've seen countries where there's a
change in government and they just they
[ __ ] can everybody bring in an entire
new intel service that's politically you
know bound to whatever administrations
come in that is a disaster that you
definitely don't want tom what do you
think
what do you think out of those uh you
know he even put ice in there so let's
throw ice in there as well which one of
those do you think we can go without
well i've always thought and i still
think that department homeland security
is there at you know airports and the
border and most most air travel is like
cross-state lines so why wouldn't
homeland security be part of fbi fbi
covers across state lines you know law
enforcement conflict in this nation has
been sort of a staple right where the
local police are working on a case
whoops it's a lot of money across state
lines fbi excuse me step back that's
ours right so this conflicts have
happened i've always thought that the
border patrol
and homeland security are redundant
since homeland security was created
after 9 11. i said well what does the
border patrol do and if it's if it's
borders and interstate things why
wouldn't the fbi have that and why did
we create
this these notions so that's my thinking
i think there's redundancy in some of it
but i agree that the fbi is an entity
and the cia entity and the nsa as an
entity i would never screw with either
one of those three
how about atf i mean alcohol yeah
tobacco i was just gonna ask that
question
i'm a big fan of all of them
i wasn't sure what the question was but
well yeah in texas it's like oh i like
alcohol
i like fireworks that's a question
in texas atf is a convenience store not
a federal bureau
the interview you did the debates the
great debates you you debated whether we
need
a war on drugs or whether we've won the
war on drugs do you have a strong
opinion of who won that argument or were
your thoughts on yeah etf i mean but atf
is a 1.4 billion dollar budget 5082
employees including
2653 special agents
760 industry operation investigators
okay
what are we doing alcohol tobacco
firearms like what do what do we so for
me you know any time like in in the
world of business when you go at the end
of the year you look at your expenses
and budget what do you look at you look
at it and you say uh
why are we spending money for this what
are we doing with this so rather than
constantly adding i think we're not
spending enough time thinking about what
we can take away and give that
responsibility to one of these other
departments that can probably do the job
we don't need to have another constantly
come up with the different depart maybe
i'm wrong i think you know on that page
i agree 100
but that's not the nature of government
the nature of government is not you know
as a as an animal is not to shrink
itself um and uh so
once once budgets get set um
you know trying to it's like every every
year
uh
in the agency
towards the end of the calendar year
you'd get this this uh note or somebody
would say something from senior
management about like what do you guys
need right what do you need do you need
more gear do you need more you know and
because we got to spend the money yeah
money's in the budget if we don't spend
it now then our next budget might be
smaller because they're going to look
and go well you guys didn't need that so
we'll reallocate those resources but i
do agree you know the the
after 9 11 when they created uh homeland
security but more importantly when they
created dni um
that was something probably could be
looked at right to shrink that because i
think they did put a lot of redundancy
in there it was just layers of
bureaucracy to combine all the various
members of the intel community and and
law enforcement and i think that's never
really functioned the way that it should
plus also i'm not a big fan of having a
dni instead of having the cia director
with a seat at the table and that's what
kind of what they did they pushed the
cia director out said oh the dni is
going to be the guy and that's a little
too political for me could and by the
way tyler go ahead ask you a great
question tyler i was just going to say
you're talking about the the budget's
always growing that's not how
bureaucracy works the government is the
single largest employer in the country
how many like i love the libertarian
perspective of small government so how
many of these organizations can we
privatize can we privatize the fbi we
privatize the cia we privatize
what have you like does it have to be a
government organization because you can
make the claim that uh if you privatize
one of these organizations it will
become biased or what have you but
you're seeing the same thing now with
all the government what would be the
benefit to privatize
i'm asking as a capitalist but i'm
asking you what's the benefit of we
privatize well it seems to me that the
private sector can
run infinitely better
anything operation-wise you're just
you're saying they're going to be more
efficient because you've got money
profit loss correct i think i think it
could be better to the taxpayer let me
ask you how do you operate better how do
you think media sells prints
it's eric prince
is that uh
from blackwell how do you think he's
portrayed as i think a lot of people
despise him i mean we have him coming on
the podcast i think in two weeks or
three weeks right yeah how is he he's
he's sold as a what he's doing
yeah so so you know that's the part as
well and then say the wrong guy any you
know i don't know
i don't know so who's this guy there's a
badly likely to nominate the new atf
head of uh after first one was pulled
eight say the president is committed to
filing the opposing enemy's vacant for
david shipman's nomination failed to get
needed support in the senate do you know
when atf got started do you know when
atf got started 1961.
so in 1961 atf so when 1961 atf got
started was alcohol legal
yes okay was tobacco legal of course
okay was uh
firearms legal yes so what what like
what is your job your job as well who
was the president that was that jfk at
that point 61.
one uh i would say yeah yeah
i'm foggy in this but remember one of
the
areas of non-violent uh crime by
organized crime was the old pink tax
sticker that used to be on top of all
the liquor bottles and they would print
all these things in the bahamas or in
the caribbean and these tax stickers
were then put on
on this and as i recall it was treasury
department before atf that actually
presided over that with even hoover
saying wait a minute this is organized
crime what are you guys doing here oh do
you think it's do you think it's weird
you got that information in your head
do you think that's that's an
interesting welcome
in your head and i'm very impressed my
head is my brain is like new york city
oh okay
by the way he just figured you out in 10
minutes we call him the walking
wikipedia
it's like where the fbi was out there
hey we're trying to bust bootleggers
over here what are you doing here well
these are tax stickers and this belongs
to the american people this little pink
thing and there were actually
non-violent criminals that were out
there printing on the tax side but that
weren't whacking each other like they
were doing prohibition
and all of a sudden we now haven't guess
what atf we'll make a new division
you're making a new department if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]